[Music]
let's be honest when it comes to
entertainment Disney knows what they're
doing there are things that Disney is
just known for from princesses to true
love's kiss to happily ever after but
there are some times when even Disney
forgot how to well Disney new here hit
the notification bell so you can stay up
to speed on all our latest videos and
click the thumbs up button if you dig
Disney as much as we do
ready here are 10 times Disney forgot
how to Disney watch until the end to
find out the most wickedly funny one on
the list that time Disney forgot about
true love so many Disney films feature a
boy and a girl falling in love it became
the hallmark of any Disney film girl is
held captive either by her stepmother or
in a tower or Anna coma
brought on by an evil sorceress girl
hopes for a man to come along and rescue
her then the prince would rescue the
girl kiss her and they would live
happily ever after
even if they only had one real
conversation they would ride off into
the sunset in their wedding attire sure
they'll work out all the
getting-to-know-you stuff after they tie
the knot yeah that'll work out but
Disney departed from that outdated
narrative with the newer animated films
Moana and Bray characters like Moana and
Merida didn't need a man to rescue them
instead these heroes overcame their own
obstacles Moana is not even a princess
and she meets her opponent without the
help of a man
Maui stayed back while Moana bravely
walked right up to took off and showed
courage and compassion and Merida fights
more do with the help of her mother and
her trusty bow and arrow that's a lot
different from Disney's Cinderella and
Snow White days that time Disney forgot
to be racist
okay real talk Disney has had some
pretty embarrassing racist moments in
their past animated films example did
you know there is a scene in the 1940
animated classic Fantasia that was so
incredibly racist they actually had to
remove it from the movie this was a
total whoops moment for Disney
apparently there was a character called
sunflower who was a darker skinned
smaller centaur who was a servant to the
lighter-skinned centaurs it was so
offensive Disney had to remove that
character from the official DVD and then
there was the issue of the crows in
Dumbo the crows have been called
stereotypically black they spoke in
heavy
southern african-american jive and the
leader of the crows was named Jim Crow
yikes there are more examples but let's
focus on the way Disney has changed to
avoid such embarrassing racism in their
present and future films when they made
cocoa they actually hired
mexican-american political cartoonist
and la Cucaracha comic creator Lalo
Alcaraz as a consultant they did this so
they wouldn't slip into the mistake of
wrongly portraying the culture of the
Mexican people it totally paid off Coco
is a beautiful tribute to the values and
traditions of Mexican families thank
goodness for that
that time Disney left the parents alive
any Disney fan can tell you there are a
lot of heroes who lose their parents in
Disney films whether it's princesses who
are locked away and never allowed to see
their parents again or Bambi's mother
getting shot in the meadow the mortality
rate for parents and Disney films is
pretty high either no one talks about
where the missing parent is like in The
Little Mermaid or Beauty and the Beast
seriously where are Ariel and Belle's
mom or they meet a horrible demise like
Simba's dad Mufasa and The Lion King
there are too many examples to even
mention them all but in the newer Disney
films it seems Disney forgot and left
the parents alive in Moana both of her
parents get to stay alive through the
whole movie
but then she does lose her grandmother
in Coco Miguel's parents grandmother and
great-grandmother are alive but then he
does lose mama Coco in the end hmm
actually Disney still has a sadistic
habit of taking out the family members
of our beloved heroes well there are
still a couple of films with living
relatives Mulan and The Incredibles
still have intact families by the end of
the film but that's a pretty small
percentage that time Disney forgot to
stereotype genders remember when Disney
films were sexist and portrayed women as
only being able to cook and clean the
good old days many feminists had a big
problem with the movie Cinderella she
was a slave to her home where she worked
constantly cooking and cleaning
she was only allowed to escape for the
night because her fairy godmother made
her look pretty and then the Prince fell
in love with her beauty
I forgot to ask her basic questions you
know like where are you from or what's
your name you had to rely on a glass
slipper because he never bothered to get
to know her in the end she was only
rewarded for her beauty then she was
whisked away to become a slave in a
bigger home so romantic but one of the
biggest examples of Disney being stuck
in stereotypical gender roles in
Cinderella is when the female Mouse says
the phrase we think the guys on Project
Runway might disagree with you little
mouse
thank goodness Disney forgot how to
pigeonhole women in Incredibles to
Elastigirl is riding a motorcycle saving
people and fighting bad guys and leaving
the sewing to someone else and it's
awesome is Disney forgetting how to
princess is it just us or does it seem
that Disney Princesses are on their way
out with movies like Coco Incredibles 1
& 2 Finding Nemo finding dory big hero 6
and inside out it's becoming harder and
harder to find a princess in a disney
story that may be because of modern
times young girls just don't identify
with a girl locked in a tower as much as
they used to
girls want adventure excitement and
independence more and more but does this
mean it's the end of Disney Princesses
maybe they just need a bit of rebranding
like Merida and brave
that's one awesomely tough princess and
there is a new unconventional princess
in town enter wreck-it Ralph princess
vanellope
she is kind of bratty she's got candy
stuck to her hair and she's the funniest
princess ever okay if Disney creates
more princesses like her
we are definitely for it and here's
something fans are just realizing with
Disney taking control of the Star Wars
franchise that means Princess Leia is
also a Disney princess mind blown
so what do you guys think is Disney
forgetting their princess ways or are
they just changing the way we see
princesses to keep up with the times the
times Disney forgot to do musicals when
one thinks of Disney movies they usually
think of big musical numbers let it go
anyone Disney has cornered the market
when it comes to characters singing and
dancing to a fully orchestrated number
Arielle gave us part of your world
Pocahontas gave us colors of the wind
Aaron gave us a whole new world with so
much success in these big musical films
it also seems like there are times when
Disney just forgot to musical the
animals in Bambi don't sing the
characters in up didn't belt out any
tunes though the opening score is pretty
catchy mr. incredible didn't sing a
beautiful ballad about his love of
Elastigirl and hero never sang to his
robot since musical numbers seem to be
what Disney is best at we wonder why
they still sometimes opt out of the big
musical numbers we guess it does make
sense for the Disney fans who don't like
musicals but we can't imagine there are
any Disney fans who don't well we do
admit it would seem weird for hero to
start singing at the science Expo The
Times Disney forgot to do happily ever
after what could be more Disney than a
happy ending well as it turns out even
Disney movies don't always end with the
happiest possible ending for the
characters take the Fox in the Hound for
example the hound dog Cooper has to save
his Fox friend Todd from being shot by
Cooper's owner get out of the way and
then they say goodbye and never see each
other again
that's not very happily ever after
here's another example wall-e it's a
sweet love story between two robots who
are trying to find life on the planet
that humans completely destroyed they
find a plant in a boot and spend a lot
of time trying to protect it and get it
in the right hands they finally do and
the people from the axiom are finally
allowed to return home but from their
habits on that spaceship their return is
not looking too good for Mother Earth it
seems like the humans will have a lot of
cleaning up to do and their bones are
all mushy and soft from living in space
for so long not to mention they're
totally addicted to space sodas and
motorized chairs it's not a very happy
ending for planet Earth and then there's
the tragedy on Disney's inside out two
words Bing bong buckets of Tears you
guys that time Disney made us root for
the villains
usually in Disney movies it's clear who
the bad guys are we all root for the
demise of the Wicked Queen and Snow
White for the fall of Cruella De Ville
in 101 Dalmatians we cheered when Jafar
was imprisoned in that tiny genie lamp
and
but lately particularly villain kids are
becoming cool this is largely because of
The Descendants movies descendants
follows the kids of the famous Disney
Villains as they struggle to become good
despite their evil roots Maleficent's
daughter mal is the star of the film's
she's joined by the Evil Queen's
daughter Evie Jafar son Jay and Cruella
De Vil son Carlos they're freed from the
Isle of the Lost where all the villains
were banished and allowed to come to
school at our Don prep with all the
princes and princesses kids everyone
loves these villain kids even when
they're casting spells and tricking
their peers that's because in the end
the villain kids learn to embrace their
inner goodness and leave most of their
wicked ways behind so very clever of
Disney to get us to root for the bad
guys all the descendants fans want to be
chillin like a villain just like their
favorite bad kids that time Disney made
us love zombies you all know what we're
talking about the Disney Channel
Original Movies zombies of course
somehow Disney managed to make zombies
cute and lovable this monster story
takes place in the lovely little town of
Seabrook about 50 years after a zombie
apocalypse thanks to a cool bracelet
device the zombies wear on their wrists
they're able to keep their hunger for
brains in check this allows them to
interact with their human friends
without posing a threat to anyone but
that doesn't stop them from singing hot
musical numbers and performing
high-energy dance numbers when a human
girl in a zombie boy fall for each other
they realize that they should celebrate
their differences instead of letting it
divide them so of course we would fall
in love with little furry Disney
characters and it's only natural that we
would swoon over a hunky prince or
Knight but how did Disney make fans
drool over zombies that's a pretty
impressive feat to pull off with all the
new characters like Zed from zombies uma
with their tentacles in descendants -
and mal is a dragon who knows what
Disney will think of next one thing is
for certain though Disney made us forget
to be grossed out by zombies the time
Disney forgot to take themselves too
seriously
with all the amazing Disney movies and
songs out there it might be easy for the
creators to get a bit full of themselves
they work really hard creating magic for
all of us to enjoy but they aren't
afraid to poke fun at themselves from
time to time one great
sample of this is in the Lion King scar
took over the pride lands in imprisons
Ozzy oh he told Zazu to see him an
upbeat song so Zazu starts to sing it's
a small world after all scar cuts him
off and tells him to sing anything but
that if you've ever been on the small
world ride at Disneyland you'll
understand why scar made that joke the
most recent example of this is in Ralph
breaks the Internet
wreck-it Ralph to vanellope bursts into
a roomful of Disney Princesses and they
all totally make fun of the damsel
princess issues of Disney past films
Rapunzel asks vanellope if people assume
all her problems were solved because a
big strong man showed up and vanellope
says that's how the princesses are sure
of vanilla peas princess status at least
Disney knows not to take themselves too
seriously and those were the 10 times
Disney forgot how to Disney thanks for
watching the things see you next time
[Music]